hi my name is Moshe schiffner I'm a PhD
student in Tel Aviv University advised
by uristeimer and edit coin in this talk
I will present the main results that are
given in the paper a framework for
adversarial streaming via differential
privacy and difference estimators
this is a joint work of idanatias edit
Cohen myself and uristeemer
so this talk consists of four parts
first we discuss the setting of
streaming in the classical sense
this setting is also called the
oblivious setting so we'll talk about
what is streaming
then we describe the setting that we
will focus in this talk the Adaptive or
adversarial setting
then we survey some pile walk
for methods for transforming algorithms
that are designed for the oblivious
setting to be opposed in the Adaptive
setting
and lastly we describe our payable
results
okay so what is streaming
streaming is a problem setting that has
requirements for both the input form as
well as constraint on the space
complexity of the algorithm
it is commonly used to model very large
data sets
a stream is a sequence of data elements
that consist the input for example the
input can be a stream of packets that
going through a router and the problem
will be to estimate some statistic over
this stream
it is also common to think of the input
elements of the data arriving one by one
in an online fashion
the constraint is that the algorithm
space must have sublinear space in the
length of the input
and in particular it cannot store the
input
as an example for a standard streaming
problem we now look on it on the problem
of distinct elements so we're just gonna
play a game
and the goal here is to count the number
of distinct Elements which are going to
be the presented emojis just try to
count
so we have a lion and a koala
and so on
dragon
so how many different images were there
so the correct answer is
11.
okay
formally we focus on the following
functions so the input is a sequence
of elements from a countable domain X
and the sequence in the left length of M
and the function under consideration
that we wish to estimate is a function
that transfer from such sequences to the
real line r
and the goal the goal is for each time t
and the prefix of the sequence s t we
want to output and estimate F hat of
this prefix such that this estimation
would be 1 plus minus Alpha Factor way
of the true value of the function over
the
prefix
so
streaming
is a subject that was studied
extensively and a seminal result was
given in 96 by Alon Matthias and zegeti
and in their
seminal paper they showed that there
existing algorithm that Alpha proximate
the F2 function that we'll discuss later
in the streaming model with space
complexity of
Alpha to the minus 2 times log n and n
here is the size of the domain Alpha is
the approximation Factor
parameter
this walk was followed by a rich
literature
giving low space approximation
algorithms to many interesting problems
and many of these results
were algorithms that are randomized
and here we have a problem
the problem that can arise is such such
randomized algorithms
uh in many cases their analysis assumes
that the input stream is fixed in
advance
but the thing is that in many real world
application this is not the case
and so we now discuss the two models
that we are interested in first the
classical and oblivious settings we
discussed now and later
the model that we're focusing the
Adaptive setting model so in the
oblivious setting first
we have a random string art that is
drawn for some distribution raw and it
will be used
in the algorithm and then for M rounds
the algorithm receive a query QT for
time T and must provide an answer 80 and
the assumption is that
for all time t
the questions the queries are fixed in
advance
and so
many space efficient algorithms exist
and this assumption is many times is
used in the analysis and it's crucial
used
and okay so our focus is in the Adaptive
setting so now we have a controller that
completely controls the Stream
so we don't have this previous
assumption so what we have we still have
the same that the random string is drawn
in the beginning of the process from
some distribution row and for M rounds
we still get querying and must provide
an answer but now the query QT may
depend on all previous answers it means
that the controller is aware of all of
the previous answers and then it can
generate whatever query that you want
for the next stage so the question is
can we give guarantees for existing
oblivious algorithms
under adaptivity under this setting
so
another question is why do we even care
about this adaptive setting so the first
answer is that we already said it
that just may appear naturally Whenever
there is a system with a feedback
so the Adaptive setting arise and then
maybe some analysis breaks
but it's also interesting
to consider the following that there is
an adversary that controls the stream
and it actually tries to fail the
algorithm
so the the feedback is not natural it is
controlled by some adversity it tries to
control the the algorithm
and this is interesting to
look on the turret from theoretical
point of view in order to draw the
limits of certain methods or find the
hardness of problems
okay so by now we established the
following that
randomized streaming algorithms may be
not robust to Adaptive inputs
so a first approach to robustify them
would be just design new algorithms
for example deterministic algorithms are
immune to adaptivity but in the case of
deterministic ones some problems have
already been shown that they have no
subliminal deterministic algorithms
additional approach this additional
bestification approach may be to take
existing oblivious algorithm to the
and to make them robust
how using grapping techniques and this
obesification approach was shown in
these five walks and we will focus on
this approach and we describe this three
first one and our result is the fourth
one
okay so we already describe what is
training and we also described streaming
in the Adaptive adversarial setting
which will be the focus in the remaining
of the talk
Now we move on to talk about prior
methods for transferring oblivious
existing algorithm to adversary server
robust one
and finally from the existing Empire
methods we'll describe also our results
in this line of
the first general rapper is the sketch
switching technique presented by gbjwy
in a high level sketch switching
technique achieves its robustness by
using different oblivious streaming
algorithm for every output modification
that is needed
then a follow-up work by hkmms used a
different approach to achieve robustness
they used a tool from differential
privacy in order to protect the internal
randomness of these oblivious algorithms
and thus showing an interesting
connection to DP
it's an interesting work
is due to wz that achieved robustness
via the same technique of page wi and
they improved the space complexity by
looking on a new oblivious algorithms
namely difference estimators
and combining several types of them in a
clever way
improved the space complexity of the
whole framework
and our walk combines these two later
works and their ideas into a hybrid
framework
we now describe the work of benelliasel
jairam wood roof and you give
and the main observation of this work is
that
if we need an alpha approximation of f
so we don't really need to modify the
output many times we actually need to
modify the output only when our
estimation changes by a factor of 1 plus
minus o of alpha
and this observation led to a stream
characterization that actually defined
the number of times that
an output modification is needed and
this string characterization is the
following it's called the flip number
flip number of a stream of of all of a
function
is the following giving a function
the flip number giving some stream is
the number of times that the value of
the function for this stream
is changed by 1 plus minus Alpha Factor
and this is denoted by Lambda so again
this characterization can be of a stream
or of a function and we talk about the
function we talk about the maximal over
all of the stream of sum length n
okay so the algorithm in high level is
as follows first get an input
Lambda the flip number bound on the
stream and an oblivious algorithm a from
the problem under consideration of
course we also have Alpha the
approximation Factor parameter and S the
input stream
and so at first the algorithm the frame
of the sketch quizzing algorithm is
initiating all of Lambda instances of
the oblivious algorithm a
then for each of the rounds
update to all of the instances
and if there is a need to modified
output use the current instance
estimation and then throw it away and
never use it again
so why it is robust
intuitively for each estimator
a towel tau is the selector of the
current
estimator only a single estimation is
modifying the output
after that we have released again
and so it's very informal but we throw
away after some information is leaking
regarding the random internal
randomization
so the takeaway from the sketch
switching technique is that we can
transform any of previous streaming
algorithm to adversary robust one with a
block of facto of Lambda in space
so whenever Lambda is small this is very
good but if Lambda is large which is the
case in some cases
it can be improved
so we now move on to talk about some
functions that are some
input cases have a large flip number
in order to discuss the flip number
bounds for some functions with respect
to two different input settings we now
look on the frequency moments functions
so the stream the stream is the elements
of pairs element
s i from countable domain X and
corresponding integer Delta I
we think of some underlying Vector that
is not explicitly maintained in the
algorithm U that is maintained or
updated with respect to the updates
so the goal the goal is to estimate FB
which is defined
as follows and P is the parameter so in
our paper we show an application for a
specific a function from this family F2
so the goal in F2 is to estimate this
function and why is F2 is important
because
this is a statistic that is used to
measure level of homogeneity across the
frequencies in the following sense
we think again about the frequency
vector and each entry of the vector
is a count of the appearances of the
stream of the corresponding element
so for some fixed L1 Norm of the vector
the F2 gets the minimum whenever the
entries are all equal if it's possible
and the value of the function increases
when the values are concentrated on less
and less entries
so let's examine the
flip number for this function for F2
okay
so we look on two uh streaming models
insertion only is the model when we are
not allowed to have negative updates and
in the textile model
any update is allowed as long as it's
bounded under some constant
so the flip number of F2 in the
insertion only model
is a 1 over Alpha Times log M and in
contrast
the flip number of F2 in the Turn Style
model is O of M and M is the length of
this stream so it's quite large
the second walk we look on is by udolph
Enzo
in a high level the main observation of
wz is that whenever the output
modification is of some small difference
with respect to the value of the output
to the previous output
then there is no need for a high
accuracy estimation of the new output in
the in in that way
they try to save space
that could be achieved provided that
there exist a new kind of algorithm that
estimate differences of the function
that under consideration
so assuming that there exists such
algorithm
and
its estimation cost is cheaper
then we can save in the estimation of
the small step this is the first idea
the one could estimate a small output
modification with space complexity that
is improved with respect to the one of
the given oblivious algorithm a for
example for relative alpha step the
space cost is improved by a factor of
alpha
indeed wz showed existence of these for
many interested problems as well as for
F2
this D is are initialized with a step
size parameter gamma allowing them to
estimate differences for some bounds
defined by this parameter
and
by clever management they showed that it
is possible to combine several different
step size d is to achieve near tight
results
for the insertion only setting
yet for the town star setting
their method is theoretically weaker
than the method
of HK MMS in the regime where Lambda is
large at the territory setting
so the takeaway here is that wz showed
an interesting method that saves the
blow up space with a factor of alpha
okay so by now we saw the following
methods we saw sketch switching
technique that modifies the output only
when we must and that gave the space
blow up of O of Lambda the flip number
and we also saw the difference
estimators which is
we have a space blow up of alpha times
Lambda which is a great Improvement and
also for the insertion only for many
functions this is a tight bound because
Lambda is small but for the 10 style
Lambda can be quite large and the
question is
what can you do in the Turn Style
setting
okay so now we describe the third walk
in this line of work which is by hasidim
Kaplan mansu Matthias and stemmer
and they show a nice connection to DP
as well as a very nice technique that
also is used for other results and
the algorithm is as follows again we
initialize many instances of the
oblivious algorithm that is received as
an input but now we only initialize
a o of square root of Lambda the flip
number
and we still feed the updates to all of
these instances but we look all the time
on all of their estimations
and we generate the output out of the
aggregation of all of these estimations
together
so why it is robust
well intuitively because each estimator
has a secret the random string and we
use privacy to protect these databases
of the random strings and it's not
straightforward but this is the high
level area we protect
the random strings together
and this method give us
an improvement of a quadratic
improvement with respect to the bjwy
again the space block we get is
all of square root of Lambda of the flip
number which is again a quadratic
Improvement
so let's move on to look at a recap so
in the insertion only model the
difference estimator is nearly optimal
so for any problem that someone
constructed a difference estimator it's
a great method
without constraints which means that we
are in the turnstile model not in the
insertion only model
so we get the following blow ups sketch
switching we have of Lambda difference
estimators Alpha times Lambda
and robust care
we get a blow up of square root of
Lambda
so the question is
can a combined approach
achieve The Best of Both Worlds because
each method wins in a different regime
so the answer is yes and exactly what we
do we present a hybrid framework that
takes both of these ideas to combine
them to a hybrid one
so First We Take all of the same type
difference estimators that are used
throughout the framework
and we group them in a set and then we
protect each of these set
with the technique of differential
privacy
it's not straightforward because we need
to introduce a generalization of the
difference estimate of the toggle
difference estimator we also needed to
change the framework
in order to fit our new needs
and then we got that in general we have
a space blow up in this hybrid framework
of square root of alpha Lambda which is
which beats both of the previous
and the second result is an application
for F2 so
F2 doesn't have a difference estimator
in the turnstile
setting but it has for the insertion
only setting and it can fail in the
terrestrial setting so the idea is to
characterize whenever this
existing Construction
fails in the turnstile setting
and then we came up with a new stream
characterization we call it twist number
that captures exactly that the number of
times that
for any stream this difference estimator
would fail and then
we introduced a monitor that capture
these failures and whenever it captures
a failure
he just reset the framework which comes
with the cost
and
for them style the combined approach we
get the following space complexity so we
have this Alpha minus 2 which is
the space complexity of the oblivious
algorithm and this is the the blow up so
the blow up is
square root of alpha Lambda plus mu and
the MU is bounded by Lambda
so here is the sum up
of the comparison of all of the four
walks that were mentioned
so in terms of General blow up
not for a specific application
so
the new method
wins all of the above for F2 the
insertion only model so both of wz and
acss Achieve optimal results or near
optimal results
and for F2 in the town style setting
our result is a can be better than hkmms
or equivalent to it if new is large it
is equivalent
okay
so
these were the citations that we used
while the talk
and that's it thank you